troisième réunion de famille pour déclic
théâtre sur scène on s'amuse mais on
n'oublie pas la saveur de
l'improvisation c'est une soirée festive
avant tout c'est une soirée de plaisir
avant tout c'est une soirée de spectacle
avant tout mais après comme on fait un
match d'improvisation il ya
nécessairement de la compétition et les
joueurs d'impro i
il aime bien c'est au jeu du qui mieux
mieux quelque part alors il ya des
règles à respecter mais en même temps si
on enlève le match à tout ça si on
enlève le l'ingrédient match en fait on
se retrouve avec quelque chose qui n'a
pas nécessairement de saveur
[Rires]
une grande famille qui écrit son
histoire depuis 1993 le temps d'une
soirée anciens et actuels de la troupe
joue ensemble
douze d'entre eux ont répondu présent on
joue à la maison de quand on était
petits c'est génial et on joue avec des
gens qui sont petits comme quand on
était petits qu'eux et compte jouer et
du coup on se dit bah ça aurait été
marrant sig moi quand j'avais été petit
j'avais joué avec des vieux et
maintenant c'est moi le veut chez déclic
théâtre on est accueilli comme comme un
frère ou comme un enfant si on est plus
jeune et on est on est chouchouté on et
dorlotés on nous emmène
on nous aide on nous fait faire des
choses qu'on n'aurait jamais fait
sans cette structure un rendez vous
réussi depuis trois ans cette année
encore la merise a fait salle comble
[Musique]
tu as entendu on arrêtait à de la trempe
l'astre heures bonjour tournis bonjour
shopi et moi l'air de grâce